What a crazy weekend.
Good to be back.
And there's so much to talk about.
We have a big media story, free speech story,
censorship story.
Actually, it's really just a media story.
Advertisers are fleeing.
Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson's program.
Why?
Because of constantly racially charged.
And quite frankly, boring and predictable
nonsense.
That is totally toxic.
And right away, the whole I don't really understand.
The First Amendment crowd is out in force
defending Tucker Carlson against second I'm
sorry, First Amendment, not Second and First
Amendment misunderstandings and so-called
charges of censorship.
But what we're actually seeing is the marketplace
of ideas that these right wingers claim to
want.
And I'm going to get to that a little bit
later after explaining to you what took place.
Being associated with Tucker Carlson's program
is bad for some advertisers in the marketplace,
and they are making the decision to bail.
So just the other day, Tucker Carlson said
on his show the protests aren't really about
black lives and that ominously, they will
come for you.
It wasn't clear when he said it if he meant
black people or who later claimed that he
met.
Oh, no Democrats, I guess.
Here's what he had to say.
This may be a lot of things.
This moment we're living through, but it is
definitely not about black lives.
And remember that when they come for you and
at this rate, they will anyone's ever been
subjected to the rage of the mob knows the
feeling.
It's like being swarmed by hornets.
You cannot think clearly.
A bunch of companies that had been advertising
on Tucker Carlson's program decided to pull
their advertising because of that and other
clips.
It wasn't just one thing.
Apparently, this includes Disney.
This includes Papa John's Pizza, which is
historically a horrible, horrible company,
a T-Mobile posh mark and some other brands.
So in a second, we're going to talk about
the free speech and censorship component to
this, because the misunderstandings that are
floating around are disturbing in terms of
the lack of understanding of anything related
to speech and censorship that they that they
portray.
But I want to be really, like extra super
clear about something here.
I said this is just business and this is just
business.
It's a market decision that's being made by
these companies.
Papa John's said they are deciding to stop
all advertising on opinion shows in general.
It's not that they're particularly upset with
what Tucker said.
They're making a business decision to pull
advertising from all opinion programs.
The other advertisers are the Papa John's
and other advertisers.
They're not bailing on Fox News.
They're out there.
They're not saying.
The problem is that FOX is so harebrained
that they allow Tucker Carlson a platform
to say the stuff.
They're just moving from Tucker Carlson to
other Fox News shows that are less under the
microscope.
Fox News said that these departures aren't
causing a financial hit because it's just
moving money from Tucker's show to other shows.
So these are not political decisions in general
in the sense that these are companies that
are still okay, sending money to Fox News
and they are okay with Fox News carrying water
in general for Donald Trump and the terrible
ideas espoused by Donald Trump and end by
the network.
But they're not going to do it on Tucker Carlson
show because it's just become negative attention
getter, so to speak.
So now that gets us to the First Amendment
free speech component, which for me is really
the most interesting thing.
A whole bunch of Trump supporting right wingers
are saying this is censorship of Tucker Carlson.
There's a free speech violation.
First Amendment, you know, fill in the blanks
with your generic censorship control concern,
trolling language, and then let's debunk these
claims one by one.
First of all, this has nothing to do with
the First Amendment.
This is the participants.
Here are advertisers, a TV channel and a TV
host.
And the audience First Amendment is not a
factor here.
The government is not abridging anyone's speech
whatsoever.
So First Amendment into the trash out the
window.
Second, this is how capitalism and the marketplace
of ideas works.
Understand that there's no coercion happening
here.
There's the non-aggression principle.
People should be pleased.
Tucker Carlson can choose.
I guess he's allowed to say whatever he wants
on his program.
And that may have repercussions.
Fox News is totally free.
No coercion.
FOX News can choose to employ Tucker or not.
They may have a particular contract with them
where if they pull them off the air, they
still got to pay them.
But they and Tucker Carlson agreed on that
contract with no government intervention.
Advertisers can choose to advertise on.
And he show they want or not to for any reason,
they can say, I don't like the suits that
Tucker Carlson wears or I don't like what
Tucker Carlson says.
They are free to decide however they want
to or not to advertise on any particular program.
Viewers like you can choose to watch or not
watch Tucker Carlson.
Viewers can choose to contact advertisers
and say, if you advertise with Tucker, I will
no longer buy your stuff.
Or they could say, unless you advertise with
Tucker.
I won't buy your stuff.
Everybody's free to do whatever they want.
Period.
And interestingly, the advertiser can choose
again, non-aggression, no coercion.
If you're an advertiser and people start writing
to you saying you'd better stop advertising
with Tucker or you'd better start advertising
with Tucker.
Either way, the advertiser can choose to listen
to those people or not.
Everybody gets to make their choices.
Now you're going to hear some people pop up
and they are they're either ignorant or they're
concerned trolling.
And they will say if you e-mail a company
and say, I will not buy your stuff if you
do X or Y like advertising with Tucker, that's
coercion.
It's not coercion.
It's called speech.
There is no violence.
It's a market place.
This is literally what the free marketeers
claim to want.
I as a buyer, can choose to buy or not buy
a product for any reason.
That is important to me.
I, as a buyer, am free to tell a company why
I am buying their product or why I am not
buying their product.
And the company can choose whether to pay
attention to me or whether to tell me to go
to hell and do whatever they want.
The company can decide, you know, if we advertise
with Tucker, we're going to lose a thousand
customers, but we might gain two thousand
because his audience is so big.
And that extra thousand customers is worth
it to us, despite the PR problem that it might
cause us to advertise with Tucker Carlson
and they can decide whatever they want.
The market is actually regulating itself here
without violence or government intervention.
The right wingers should be cheering this,
but they're not.
They want to frame it as a liberal mob trying
to hurt someone's ability to earn a living.
We don't even know, by the way, whether Tucker's
income is affected by the number of advertisers
his show has.
It may not be.
We don't know.
They are pathetic and they are predictable
and they're so boring.
I mean, it's just it's getting so old that
they either don't understand or pretend not
to understand how markets and free speech
and censorship actually work.